[Musique]
Chantal Hébert martine Biron Michel
David bonsoir bons
qui a fait une blague j'ai besoin de
densifier ma relation avec le maire
marchand on va parler de ça mais d'abord
on va écouter le meilleur marchand la
veille monsieur Legault aujourd'hui on
revient
on confond occupation du territoire et
densification
il y a quelque chose qui est important
que les gens
voient clair et le gouvernement peut pas
aller jouer dans ce discours populiste
là qui est vraiment dangereux quand
j'entends le gouvernement nous servir ce
document cet argument là je pense que
c'est fallacieux
j'ai vu aussi le chroniqueur de la
presse
registre la bombe
dans le fonds
je vais essayer de me concentrer sur
Bruno
[Musique]
on va développer une amitié sans
condition
puis je vous promets qu'on va essayer
densifier notre relation dans les
prochains mois
c'est important oui de densifier nos
villes de limiter l'étalement urbain
puis une des façons de faire ça c'est
décontaminer les terrains qui sont dans
les villes puis pour moi le stunté on
sait que ces mères font face à un
gouvernement un gouvernement de la carte
qui est littéralement figé dans une
conception des années 50 concernant le
développement des villes
densifier d'un côté
étalement de l'autre Michel David y
a-t-il deux visions qui s'affrontent
actuellement dans le jeu politique de
ces nouvelles personnalités municipales
qu'on apprend à découvrir et d'autre
part du gouvernement de la claque oui
tout à fait c'est clair on l'avait vu
déjà à Montréal avec Madame plante à
Québec avec Bruno marchand plus
récemment mais là on voit que dans dans
beaucoup d'autres villes au Québec de
ville moyenne disons en termes de
dimension il y a des jeunes élus
ameresse qui eux aussi ont une vision
diamétralement opposée à celle de la CAQ
et monsieur Legault c'est on a
l'impression de qui prend un cours
d'étalement urbain 101 et qui commence à
découvrir un peu comme il y avait
découvert l'importance des changements
climatiques de l'environnement pendant
la dernière campagne électorale en 2018
le tout d'un coup à l'approche de
l'élection il se rend compte que c'est
une préoccupation importante un peu
partout au Québec et je pense qu'il y a
un petit choc là monsieur Legault
Martine un petit choc oui certainement
une nouvelle génération qui arrive et
ils ont les changements climatiques à
coeur monsieur Legault c'est pas montrer
en 2018 en tout cas que c'était sa
priorité il y avait une page blanche en
termes de changement climatique là il a
évolué c'est sûr que lui ça va un
élection et les maires faut comprendre
que c'est très important là tous les
chefs politiques disent à leur candidat
ou à leur députés bon allez vous en a
votre circonscription parler rencontrer
vos maires écouter vos maires discuter
avec vos mères ayez la pluie de vos
mains c'était la pudement tu as déjà une
longueur d'avance alors là Monsieur Lego
s'en va en élection il y a besoin de de
l'appui des mers remarqué que les mers
ont quand même besoin de lui alors il va
mettre en place une politique de
l'aménagement du territoire pour essayer
de répondre à une partie des
revendications les maires aussi sont
politisés leur rappelez-vous dans le
temps il y avait les mers rouges les
mers bleus là la dynamique a changé mais
ils sont aussi politiques politiques une
seconde Martine rapide en salle
politique de l'aménagement du territoire
doit arriver bientôt nous a dit la
ministre là cette semaine je crois
probablement la fin du mois et il va y
avoir une place concernant il va y avoir
un chapitre en tout cas sur les
Allemands urbain c'est intéressant
Chantal parce qu'on voit des conceptions
qui s'affront on voit qu'il y a quelque
chose qui avance fonda l'impression dans
ce débat là
oui et la donne a changé parce que quand
c'était Montréal et Valérie plante et la
CAQ qui avait des visions différentes
c'était pas sur un terrain électoral ou
la carte est forte ou vraiment besoin de
compter beaucoup de points mais là ce
qu'on voit c'est que la nouvelle
génération de mer et ça s'étend au
Québec Gatineau fête la liste Longueuil
et là on est rendu dans du terrain
sensible et avec des mères on le
demandeur est tout frais et en politique
vous le savez ceux qui ont le mandat le
plus frais ont généralement une longueur
d'avance sur ceux qui veulent même une
réélection parce que le pouvoir ça use
et la fatigue des électeurs s'installe
alors pour la coalition à venir Québec
il y a un besoin impératif de se
densifier dans sa relation avec ses
mains là parce que c'est déjà un point
faible la lutte au changement climatique
pour la coalition à venir Québec et là
ça vient se confirmer dans le pratique
là donc oui il y a un signal jaune qui
qui
s'allume clignote en jaune attention ici
il faut faire attention au caricature
densifier c'est pas dire des tours de 30
étages toutes des conduits il y a
plusieurs façons de densifier très bien
un petit extrait du débat d'hier
ouais
[Musique]
je vous ai présenté ça pour montrer le
format de ce débat on s'attendait un
débat vigoureux avec des débats
justement il y a eu beaucoup de
questions de Tom cloud notre ancien
collègue de cityville qui posait des
questions mais tellement de questions
qu'il y avait pas de débat un petit mot
Chantal sur le format à côté de ça notre
dernier fédéral puis Dieu sait qui avait
des contraintes avaient l'air beaucoup
plus libre presque mais le imaginez
avoir des notes de trombone quand on
prononce le nom du premier ministre dans
un débat politique de l'opposition
officielle il faut quand même le faire
et avoir des des raquettes de ping-pong
pour prendre la parole et plus avoir de
droite paroles dans le cas de quand on
parle de lutte contre les changements
climatiques
écoutez moi et vous on fait de la radio
et de la télé et ni vous ni moi on est
capable d'énoncer une idée cohérente et
de la défendre en 15 secondes et c'est
ce qu'on a demandé toute la soirée à ces
gens-là 15 30 secondes quand on est
généreux
tout un débat ils sont tombés dans le
piège ok mais on va on va quand même
parce qu'il y a eu malgré tout des
échanges
sur la Banque du Canada monsieur
poirievre on veut l'entendre qui dit moi
dès que j'entre en poste si je suis élu
je vais renvoyer le gouverneur de la
Banque du Canada parce qu'il s'occupe
pas bien de l'inflation on écoute cet
échange là avec Monsieur chalet
tour de table Michel ça c'est un exemple
de deux visions très différentes
monsieur Charrey monsieur Poirier
de la misère
la Banque du Canada et toute l'histoire
du Bitcoin et puis on le voit
aujourd'hui avec les fondements
j'imagine que monsieur polliet va s'en
faire parler mais il y avait quelque
chose de tellement contradictoire dans
ce qu'il disait écoutez moi j'accuse le
gouverneur de la Banque du Canada d'être
à la salle du gouvernement libéral il
imprime de l'argent il fait monter
l'inflation il est pas indépendant moi
j'arrive là je vois le sacré dehors
toute une indépendance pour le
gouverneur de la Banque du Canada tout
ce chapitre là je pense monsieur
monsieur Charrel là a marqué des points
en présentant et les propos de Monsieur
poignet de laisser penser en présentant
ce gars comme une responsable qui serait
dangereux de nommer aux délire ou pas ce
premier ministre alors ça je ne sais pas
il y a rien gagné de ce côté-là Martine
chez les conservateurs c'est quand même
un argument qui peut réussir le trouver
une oreille parce que l'inflation c'est
quand même un enjeu important alors il
cible l'enjeu alors ce qui fait c'est
qu'il se positionne évidemment il y a
deux visions très différentes là celle
de Monsieur charey qui est plus restons
avec le statut cool le status quo
restons calme est-ce que ce que Monsieur
poignet arrive c'est qu'il se démarque
littéralement en disant ben on est
devant un gouvernement très dépensier
nous on va travailler autrement et on va
on va changer ce qui se passe à la
Banque du Canada évidemment c'est un peu
gros mais quand même je pense que ça
c'est une des propositions qui peut
trouver une oreille ou partie
conservateur Chantal
aux parties conservateur je sais pas
auprès des membres que Monsieur poilliev
recrute pour se faire élire oui et
lorsqu'on a vu hier c'est une occasion
d'essayer de rattacher la réalité une
campagne électorale ça se passe sur un
scène beaucoup plus large qu'une course
sur les deux chiffres et la galaxie
peut-être près de chez nous mais
complètement différent dans laquelle
monsieur poignet fait campagne et il y a
pas réussi c'est presque une anime c'est
pas seulement Jean chalet tout le monde
qui sait quoi que ce soit sur l'économie
dit ça ce sont des recettes
d'apprentissage sorciers qui tiennent
pas la route et qui même certains
colonisent qu'on identifie plus ça des
courants conservateurs disent qu'il
amène unding de devenir Premier ministre
ça l'empêchera possiblement pas de
gagner mais le danger c'est que la
crédibilité économique du Parti
conservateur est en train de prendre une
claque parce que le meneur de sa course
se promène en disant des choses par
rapport à ça il peut pas corriger le
gouverneur de la Banque du Canada sans
l'approbation du conseil
d'administration de la Banque du Canada
alors il parle un peu pour rien dire en
plus mais Chantal je reprends une des
choses
ça va lui nuire dans l'autre course une
érection mais d'ici là ça lui nuire pas
tellement pour devenir chef ce genre de
ok ce que le débat d'hier a fait c'est
que ça a plongé une partie du Parti
conservateur
dans une profonde dépression c'est à
dire que plus ça va plus le fossé entre
les conservateurs
qui s'identifie pas à pied à poilie avec
qui trouve que ce discours là était
responsable et les membres qui vont
voter et qui sont qui ont été recrutés
s'élargi écoutez 70% des Canadiens
pensent que la manifestation
Ottawa l'occupation du centre-ville
d'Ottawa était responsable lui il est
défend et là vous pouvez décliner la
liste la majorité des Canadiens pense
que les vaccins est imposent et
aujourd'hui il y en a tout le monde que
le gouvernement du Canada vous espionne
à la pharmacie au centre d'achat il
parle à une frange qui est de plus en
plus éloignée de l'électorat
qui va devoir y aller en gouvernement et
les conservateurs qui sont pas de sa
mouture se disent comment on va faire
pour vivre et amener notre partie plus
loin après cette course je fais entendre
un autre extrait puis justement ayant en
tête cette question comment il ferait
pour vivre ensemble après bilan serait
quand monsieur poignet réattaque se le
fait depuis jour 1 monsieur Charest sur
son bilan lui en écoute
social
[Applaudissements]
Henry Dustin
après cette course là Michel David bon
monsieur Charrey super je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il voudrait des
candidats pour être députés mais on
imagine mal ces deux personnes là dans
le même parti après Michel mon imagine
très mal puis on l'imagine encore plus
mal dans le même gouvernement on peut
pas avoir un gouvernement dans les deux
le numéro 1 est vraisemblablement le
numéro 2 serait aux antipodes ça a aucun
sens
le bout de Monsieur poignet quand il
attaque monsieur charrette de toutes les
façons d'être un ancien libéral là là il
marque des points mais du même coup à
chaque fois il y a approfondie la
division à l'intérieur du parti et ça ça
peut pas disparaître du jour au
lendemain c'est bon je pense que le
lendemain de cette course là peu importe
le gagnant ça va être et pouvoir table
en tout cas il y a deux il y a des
sections Martine qui pourront pas se
recoller c'est clair je pense pas que
Monsieur Charest hyper là je pense pas
qu'on voit le revoir
sur une tribune avant longtemps je pense
pas qu'il va rester conservateur mais ce
courant
mais c'est sûr que ça va te partie
profondément divisée et
quand on entend les messieurs polyèvre
gagne quand on entend le programme qu'il
présente ça va être très difficile aussi
pour
d'aller en élection devant la population
générale le présentement il s'adresse
aux membres qui veut séduire mais sortir
de là ça va être tout un défi là ça va
être très difficile la frange
progressiste qui est quand même beaucoup
plus dans l'Est suivra pas dernière
extrait de la soirée c'est sur
l'avortement monsieur Charret qui veut
pousser polyèvre à dire à le dire je
suis pro choix on écoute
a été assez clair d'une part je pense
que oui mais est-ce que il ne voulait
pas l'intro pour pas nuire à ce vote
important chez les militants qui sont
anti choix
en gros l'enjeu ce sont les votes de
Madame Lewis qui est la seule candidate
de la droite religieuse qui est
anti-avortement parmi les candidats et
là-dessus le langage corporel de Madame
Lewis vis-à-vis de Pierre pollière ça
donne pas l'impression qu'elle a dans
son cœur alors quelque part oui Jean
cheri a probablement compter quelques
points là pas parce qu'il le dit moi je
suis au choix mais parce que parler des
conservateurs sociaux d'une part et
d'autre part parce qu'il y a mis en
évidence le fait que Pierre pollière
leur faisait pas de promesses ça
pourrait être utile dans des taux de
scrutin parce que ces gens-là vont
devoir avoir un deuxième un troisième et
quatrième choix s'il y en a un et aucun
des autres candidats leur offre ce que
Madame Lewis
tour de ta Martine c'était intéressant
parce que effectivement on voit que la
stratégie c'est vraiment de préparer le
deuxième tour et d'ailleurs madame quand
elle leur dit qu'elle était provie dans
la salle elle a été applaudi à peu près
le seul moment où on a entendu des
applaudissements sur ce sur cet enjeu là
alors la salle
envoyé le message où elle se positionner
et le flou artistique que veut maintenir
monsieur poignet œuvre m'apparaît
vraiment une stratégie pour le deuxième
tour
c'est à peu près tout ce qu'on s'est dit
à le calibre parce que quand on écoute
au débat là ça a pas été
particulièrement instructif disons il y
a alors ça oui les produits disons dur
vont voter pour elle mais j'imagine que
pour tout le reste
il me donnait l'impression que en
général ils font davantage aller du côté
de pollière que du côté de Charest alors
ce que monsieur paullief veut pas c'est
de le dire trop souvent est-ce que
Monsieur Charet veut lui faire dire
c'est l'entendre souvent le dire mais il
l'avait dit Monsieur Poirier mais bon
pas trop fort ok
un dernier mot sur patrick Brown qu'on
voit pas beaucoup mais on l'a vu est
invité évidemment mais il dit moi je
fais campagne sur le terrain est-ce
qu'il sera un facteur parce que lui
c'est deuxième choix on imagine beaucoup
vont aller du côté de Monsieur Charrey
en tout cas c'est le calcul je me suis
chargé est-ce que il est un facteur ou
peut-être moins qu'on croyait rapidement
ma Chantal
dur à dire et il fait il recrute
beaucoup au sein des communautés
culturelles première question est-ce que
c'est vote vont avoir vraiment un
deuxième choix parce que c'est le danger
à chaque fois c'est pas parce que vous
avez vous voulez appuyez un candidat
vous êtes obligé d'en avoir un deuxième
un troisième un quatrième mais c'est sûr
que quand je serai compte sur lui le
mystère c'est est-ce qu'à la fin il
pourrait avoir plus de votes que
j'enchai au premier tour
Martine moi je trouvais qu'il était pas
très à l'aise monsieur Brown plus ou
moins peut-être moins préparé que les
autres et lisait beaucoup ces notes même
quand il débattait
je me suis demandé un peu pourquoi il
était là et où il s'en allait là mais je
le sentais pas vraiment
confortable et c'est quand même
quelqu'un que la politique dans le corps
là ça m'a surpris oui c'est une bonne
remarque effectivement il y avait il y a
pas l'air à l'aise Michel sur sur la
suite vous voyez la seule chose à peu
près moi que j'ai retenu de Monsieur
Brown c'est ses qualités le seul à se
prononcer pour une exclusion aérienne en
Ukraine mais pour le reste honnêtement
il y a beaucoup de gens je pense qu'il
espérait voir un match Revenge du débat
de la semaine dernière puis monsieur
monsieur branle arrivé là un peu comme
un cheveu sur la soupe
il y a pas trop d'affaires là maintenant
ceci étant dit je suis pas capable
d'évaluer son tyran là en Ontario en
particulier alors dans quelle mesure il
va vraiment lui et ses deuxièmes choix
vont être déterminants honnêtement j'ai
de la difficulté à l'évaluer je dois y
aller mais pour un match revanche
j'aurais fallu qu'il y ait un vrai match
puis pour ça il rétablir les laisser les
chevaux galoper un peu ok quel livre
qu'elle fait une autre fois merci
Chantal Martin Michel très apprécié
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI